hello everybody hope they are good first
of all I'm sorry for the audio um You
probably hear me different because I'm
traveling so I don't have my headphones
with me but um anyway because I'm
traveling I'm going to try to make um
the next videos well for the next uh 3
to four months a bit shorter maybe under
10 minutes so uh that's going to be kind
of like the goal of video so um this is
my Bitcoin prediction for today at the
end of the video going to understand why
uh I'm going to go uh through different
time frames so the first time frame I'm
going to go through is going to be the
daily time frame um let me take this and
put it here you can see that we are
inside this range still okay this was a
previous range you can see here okay
then we broke to the upside we went
another range we fell back into this
range and we is still uh here okay so no
much has changed let me change the color
to Yellow there okay and you can see
that we're right now above the range
highs okay this is the daily time frame
so this is very important because if we
manage to close several candlesticks
above the range highs that's going to
give us an idea that we could favor
higher
prices
okay if you go into the 1 hour time
frame you can see that the chart is a
bit of extended okay price tends to go
all the time to the 1 hour 50a you can
see what happens uh historically look at
this move for example okay you can see
here price goes up very quickly and then
it comes back down to test the one hour
50a test a support continue tested a
support continue going up okay so that's
kind of what I'm expecting here I need
to see a test of the 1 out 50 ma okay
that's what this project ction is based
on now if you look at yesterday's move
that was quite unfortunate uh move
because it was based on fake news so
well um you guys uh most of you are in
Twitter so you know what happened um Co
Telegraph is the biggest um news Outlet
in in the space uh they released uh fake
news of the Bitcoin ETF um by mistake of
an employee so you can see how you know
uh Bitcoin reacted to that it went to
30k look at this week it's insane now
some of you might be wondering if this
week can get filled and my answer is yes
I mean why not it's a huge imbalance in
the chart so you mean if there was any
gamblers taking shorts from here and I
see gamblers because uh is a very risky
play because you could have taken a
short for example here they have been
stopped okay to because of taking a stop
here have getting a stopped get another
short here you can stop again so if if
if any took a short in this Z okay I'm
not going to say the word trailer if any
if any gamer took a short from this Zone
here and it's still holding it then
you're going to have a stop stops here
okay so that's what I mean this is still
a huge imbalance in the chart and and I
think if you go to the Bitcoin dominance
chart and you look at that week okay
you're want to see how it's pretty much
failed
okay so I mean you can see how it's
pretty much failed the 50% of it so U
that's what I mean why not why can't
Bitcoin do the same guys um but I still
believe that it's more likely that we
retest the one50 ma first so um this is
my prediction for for today now if we
close the daily candlesticks below the
range highs then nothing has changed
okay because you're are still going to
be inside this
range and you know there is possibility
that you continue raining here okay but
if you start to see some candlesticks
close in the daily time frame of the
range highs then you know we want to
favor higher prices you even have here
liquidity pool
okay this is a liquidity pool around
31,500 so that would be the next Target
for me okay um
again
um well actually look even in the daily
time frame you can see a new week here
okay it's around $400 week so why not
okay that could be another Weck to get
fieldable anyway um I would like to see
Bitcoin closing above the Range High so
we could have that continuation B
I think that it's more likely that we
come to the 1 hour 50 okay I don't
believe that you know we've been since
Sunday going up and not today Tuesday
but look at the price difference it's
huge it's like a $2,000 difference
without counting the week that went to
30k by the way 30k exactly round number
not a
coincidence okay so that's my prediction
this was the
push and um I don't know if this could
continue higher even towards this Zone
and then come again to the 1 hour 50a so
that's kind of what I'm looking for
today the New York session um this is
still opening uh in 2 hours 5 minutes
from right now what I'm recording and to
be honest right now I'm just noticed
that this could be an information here
okay there you
go okay another Confluence to to to this
idea but that's a potential pattern
developing there now I want to take you
to high block Capital because there are
a few confluences there that I've seen
that could support this
idea why have Lo Capital 12 hours time
frame liquidation heat map and I haven't
updated yet okay but this was um the
chart that I saw right before making
that projection and what I saw was
basically the a
28,600 in the 12 hours time frame there
were qual of liquidations okay so that
was my idea my here was a push up
towards 28,600 to hit all those
liquidations and then I'll drop now I'm
going to update this hit map and you're
want to probably going to see this Zone
get taken
out okay let's have a look guys there
you go
28,600 they take that zone look at that
guys I mean it doesn't even go higher it
just goes high enough to take that zone
and then you can see price is um you
know dropping $200 so um that's what I
mean and now if you check here at
28,000 the liquidity there is increasing
you have that a yellow bar in the
liquidation hit maps and that is telling
you that that's the next zone of
Interest okay and I believe that the 1
or 50
ma is inside this area so uh this is a
good Confluence you can already see the
first part uh playing out so hopefully
now we can go towards this one okay is
what I'm looking for today now let's
continue looking out there um hit Maps 7
Days time
frame um I mean not really much except
that liquidity at 26,400 this is still
there again I believe that with this
move um this has probably changed quite
a lot I'm not
sure um if H um is counting these
liquidations right in this one uh
because you guys know that they don't um
reduce liquidation I they can only add
them or or keeping them the same because
they don't know when Traders are closing
their positions so I'm not sure what
happened yesterday after that week to
30k to be honest I don't know if they
are updated I don't know if I can uh Tru
this liquidation hit m in higher time
frame right now um in higher time frame
the same one month time frame a lot of
liquidations at
25,800 and
26,400 but I'm not going to continue
looking into higher time frame for that
reason now if you go to the liquidation
levels we can see that there are 80
billion worth of long liquidation so
that means that uh Longs right now at
risk you can even see here total s
liquidations 178 total long liquidations
600 so that basically is telling you
that for every short position there are
four long positions open pretty much
okay so that is telling you the long
positions are at risk now if you check
the liquidations this is quite chaotic
because you can see a lot of bubbles
here but this is what I mean this is the
imbalance that the week leaves behind
Okay you can see a lot liquidations all
the way to
31k that's insane but most important for
me are these s here okay even up to$ 500
million dollar okay worth of liquidation
so you got here
29,900 you got
29,600 and 29,00 so to the UPS those are
be the main zones for me okay for now as
I said I'm not looking for long
positions I'm favoring
shorts in the very short term because
I'm expecting a a retrace towards the 1
or 50 then we're want to see how the
daily candle closes if it closes above
the range highs then you know we we have
then um an argument to to say that you
know it's likely that price Targets this
liquid ation to the upside and then to
the downside you go a lot of
liquidations at
27,400 and
26,800 okay so that will be pretty much
it um overall this chart is only telling
you that longs are at risk and if you
are in Long don't for to take profits
because it's likely that the price start
it starts to to retrace a bit towards
the 1 or 15 May okay um that's what I'm
seeing for today
um again it's no Financial advice we'll
see tomorrow um if this plays out or not
the the charts at the moment are the
chart is insane I mean you've seen
yesterday you got an Asian pum on this
false move then you got the ETF fake
news um it just insane also last week uh
there was a lot of things going on in in
the chart so it's going predictable at
the moment but um you mean by by taking
all these
confluences that that's my main idea
okay I retrace towards the 1 hour 50 me
so that's pretty much everything guys uh
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon